a new Gallup poll suggests that going to
pursue Aegis colleges
doesn't actually make that any happier
in life or
in work this comes from a survey about
29,000 college graduates
by Purdue University in with look at
fighting five in six report doing great
in at least one Spears sense of purpose
financial security
physical help close relationships or
community pride
only 11 percent are thriving in all five
areas and well-being
and the percentages did not vary based
on whether the grads went to a top 100
school in the US News
& World Report rankings or one at the
bottom 100
this kind interesting because we put so
much emphasis on going to the right
college
no matter how much it costs and
apparently caused a lot these days
I am I want to add new york state school
to any Binghamton
which is perfectly fine school pretty
good academic school it's not a lot
about their
stop I study politics so I guess
something translated into
my life now I am does this surprise you
are or not surprise you that
going to these better schools isn't
actually equating
to any sort a bigger sensor for filming
in life it's surprising to NPR
yeah pets that I you know
academia as the end all be all yeah it's
not surprising because we're first in
opera duo also
is formidable people and from the alley
and that's why you would probably think
that if you write
well the statement made by Purdue Univ I
think a little bit about your tampering
mining on there so they were at right is
a little shout
and the fact that I'm no I didn't go to
college for in the traditional 10th
yeah I mean I didn't go to college I
went for about a year and a half
well I did not know the story did not
tell you that I am
changes II and I got lucky that I am
working in an industry where it doesn't
necessarily
you don't have to go to cut to work in
television
on but to get a lot of talking about it
I had a good report I know I just read
your mind rather you can rely the axiom
formation is like
I want to call it like it's a higher
ally college kids and they're really
don't know
they're like drunk they they have the
sheepish marking mentality that like
sorry sorry I yeah but a
you know it's it's just I think that at
least to me as I've gotten my older
my my later twenty's I realize that it's
a lot less important
where he went to school and more about
like what you can actually do on a daily
basis and how I connected you are
with knowledge yeah now what does this
say about our
college system because you'd like to
think that if you go to a good school
you will get a good job you will have
more money will somehow be happier I
think that
sorted the mid-america that's how it's
gonna work
and yet we're finding out that I think
it's wonderful I think it's fabulous I'm
glad to hear this because you know so
many other people that
I've met you know just from just all
locks who
our talk you will talk about how oh you
know you had to go to a perceived as
University if you want to get into this
special on
up society and if that means that you
can still be happy and still have a
fulfilling career and still do work that
you think is important and satisfac-
in satisfactory to you then it's
wonderful that you can go to just a
regular old
state school and still be able to
achieve those things you know
one other things that they don't talk
about and this particular study
is about the network that you get from
going to anally
University eso I think that can have
very large impact on your ability to get
a job right now to graduation and the
industry for choice but beyond that if
it doesn't make you happier I think that
that's really a boost
to everybody who wants to go to college
in and feels like they're somehow
starting off
at at a deficit because they didn't go
to an elite University yet is this also
participating that the college's people
talking about this and other colleges
are pricing themselves
out a relevance that people we don't
have a great economy I C
people can't afford to go to these
places anymore and then they're finding
out the college graduates are getting
the jobs that they use the air
so is colleges like just the general
thing becoming
some wood I mean if you ask me you
coming from
gather everything I didn't go with
because I
had used college as a way to open a
budget doors where I could like work my
ass off and have opportunities
that happen way sooner than I had
actually planned on
that was like for me you know to work
with with larry king was like I couldn't
pass up that opportunity to have
that happen right so it was like I
probably would have continued to go to
school I just got really lucky
and you know I have the idea that like
for the pursuit of knowledge I would
probably go back someday
this whole thing goes away well you know
there are issues with the
you know in some places like if you need
to get a job in a in a regular industry
not an hour seminar
yeah Joe not against any more like you
need to get
a job in an engineering field and you
must have yet that if you want to work
and one of these other
you know capacities you must have a
degree so knowing that it's actually
possible
is pretty cool but you know we remember
there's a student loan crisis as well
and I think that also negatively impact
people's happiness and satisfaction
later on when you are
I don't know struggling under crushing
debt you're saying if you went to a
prestigious college and then you will
got added that you were a hundred
thousand dollars and that it might
affect your day general state will be
yeah it might be a little less happy
about to
you know but there was a good a good
point in that article in that specific
study
about how good teachers good teachers
and good mentors
really made a big difference in those
people that reported high satisfaction
so I think that that is a great avenue
to
to look at you know how do we get better
teachers you know because the people are
satisfied with their lives ten twenty
years on because they had a teacher who
cared about them he was a really good
teacher
yeah I think that that shows one a great
avenue for which
you know through which we can create you
know better outcomes for people
everything on the teachers and the
mentoring and some did you get that
teacher in high school doesn't
right from college in a good teachers
being being this
this launching point for good life I
think that's really